نحن نعطيكم صوره المكان الاكبر الذي حدثت
فيه انهيارات ارضيه وانشقاقات ارضيه مرعبه
ومهوله نحن في منطقه تبعد عن مدينه هاتاي
عشرين كيلو متر عن المركز مدينه انطاكيا
هذه هذا المكان حدثت فيه انشقاقات ارضيه
وصخريه مرعبه في هذا المكان في احد
الاماكن عمق اكثر من ثلاثين اكثر من 30
متر تحت الارض هناك صخور طبقات صخريه ظهرت
نزلت في هذا الوادي الذي حصل جراء الزلزال
الذي حصل قبل ثمانيه ايام اهالي القريه
قريه تبهان هي على مسافه تقريبا 300 او
500 متر من هذا المكان قالوا لنا تحدثنا
الى مختار القريه قال مختار القريه ان
ايقظنا على صوت انفجار مهول جدا وتوقعنا
ان قنبله او صاروخا سقطت في الارض بالقرب
من القريه ثم عندما خرجنا الى الشوارع وكل
سكان قريه خرجوا جراء هذا الانفجار كما
وصفوه وجدوا ان الدخان يتصاعد وهو في
الحقيقه الاتربه تتصاعد نتيجه هذه
الانهيارات الارضيه ولذلك سكان هذه القريه
معظمهم غادر القريه خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه ويمكن ان تحدثه هذه الهزات
الارتداديه في القريه وفي المنطقه هناك
عشرين بيت سقط عشرين بنايه في هذه القريه
سقطت جراء هذا هذه الانشقاقات التي حصلت
في المكان نحن نعلم انها طاي هي المدينه
الاكبر التي تضررت بهذا الزلزال والخسائر
هي الاكبر الذي حصلت في تركيا هي في مدينه
هاتاي هناك بحسب
لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه التي
فحصت المنازل قالت انه هناك اكثر من 29
بيت تم فحصه هناك
6300 بيت على الاقل يجب ازالتها بالكامل
هناك 2000 بنايه
ازالها الزلزال بالكامل اي ان الخسائر
كبيره جدا